oh so should we just all split it four
ways yeah it works for me
cool
sounds perfect cool yeah that's great
love splitting
do you want to get indian food for lunch
yes
okay uh noon
you can take the pepperonis off right uh
yeah i'm not really hungry anyway it's
fine yeah
i'll get something else
with beef
don't you ever miss bacon don't you ever
miss steak don't you ever miss
hamburgers
can i eat anything here oh i could get
the
rice wait i can eat everything
here i can never be a vegetarian could
never be a vegetarian
i could never be a vegetarian do you eat
chicken nuggets
enjoy bacon
of course but where do you get your
protein where do you get your protein
where do you get your protein hey do you
want to split something
yeah i'm going to be getting the veggie
entree though oh that's fine
there's no meat in it oh i'm vegetarian
oh amazing yeah let's split it okay
perfect so if you're mexican how are you
a vegetarian
you can't be mexican and vegetarian at
the same time are you a unicorn